so
yeah
that worked
first help you
huh
oh birdie i got i know i
got you e o no puberty already
i can't go in today i got
puberty i sick with puberty tell the
boss all those puberty so we're sure
ahead today i can't
come in i've got the cubes welcome
to threesome thank you same my name
is your well napkin hi my name
is paul f tompkins my name is
scott vickerman me wow what's your real
name victor
b for victory ah what if you
ah
lord you sounded like the the sound
that people sometimes put on a video
on instagram or tiktok where ah it's
like maybe a bitter be like a
dog jumping or a baby falling over
whatever yeah and the noises are like
me and was like me you know
the one i'm talking about huh
yeah it's a good one no no
and not to be a fucking idiot
but where do they find these sounds
and how do they reward child when
i want to for the record i've
never tried only ever want to see
the originals one time i asked about
one about um oh look at him
very distinguished gentlemen that people use a
lot and i was like yeah where
did that come from and then somebody
said
it came from this and was getting
do i wonder where it came from
but i wonder how did they find
the audio to get that sound and
use it for the likenesses yeah i
mean like yeah i'm sure they're searching
it but then it's like how you
search yeah like are you saying ah
that kind of thing i'm gonna go
we are you searching that yeah i
mean maybe i should just try to
get into tiktok and reels and
like see what i can make i
feel like i could be really cool
like an untapped resource for you laura
and i really think yeah absolutely so
much good stuff could be happening if
i got on speaking of which i'm
now on cameo you fucking are yeah
yeah yeah yeah your goddamn mind would
have known what happened paul i'm gonna
i'm gonna do it the way that
i i told you that i wanted
to do it so no one can
trick me into white supremacy stuff and
how much money have you made my
man how much you charge quality i
okay truth be told by the time
people are hearing this i'm on it
as of right now the c o
i'm not on it yet but i
wrote here's what i love it's happening
and how much are you charging starting
at fifty dollars i love that i
think you could go higher but i'll
let i'll let that be we're gonna
start a fifteen seat but by the
way janey is spending the money already
she is this is going to be
a cash cow for us and i'm
like you gotta lower your expectations what
what is she buying usually buying like
a new lawnmower
rowers she want a fur coat here's
what i'm gonna say you're i'm going
to say to all our listeners if
you have fifty dollars that you would
spend without noticing it you need to
know from paul right now you know
what i agree if you know are
doing that well the fifty dollars isn't
here i gotta feel that at all
by three how about that
fifty dollars no i guess huh
yeah
do it damn um yeah that sounds
amazing and but and you you are
two things doesn't it you're donating all
the the proceeds to charity you were
telling me before the show i've tried
well already called cheat every everything after
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars goes
directly to charity so we're just gonna
ever bass with everything just guys
base amount of zero fifty grand yes
i don't think i'd even say that
cover my logistics yeah i'd should say
travel lodging everything over one hundred fifty
k per year you'll donate to charity
yeah exact notes i exceed every year
one seed per month per month which
two
love of them is a year so
yeah in a way everybody's right yeah
and that's what i'm going to do
yeah yeah i love that but yeah
like cameo for me ah all i'm
going to do is whatever i wanna
do i think that's a great idea
i'm just gonna like riff and it'll
be it'll be fun and it's like
get it for somebody that maybe won't
like it i love it i think
people who who think you're great which
is everyone who knows of you will
want this so those of you not
the people who know me whoa no
i want one of those angler divided
i wouldn't expect people who know you
to buy your cameo i hope not
that would be weird you know what
if i got a cameo from you
whoa whoa skye what if i bought
one too oh
give you them for free no no
i want i wanna buy it you're
my friend i want cameo to get
a cut
ah we'll see this might i like
hopefully it's not going to be something
that i absolutely wish i hadn't done
you can bail whenever yeah you can
always fail it's true it's true no
no it'll be great great what if
i just did one and then bailed
sounds if one for janie
you do one it's up on the
site and you're no longer active
no you should do is you should
do the scorsese role where you do
one for them one for them one
for me yeah exactly suddenly you have
a ton of cameos for yourself yes
i still think to myself i pay
for them i don't like how they
show examples on your page because i
feel like a lot of people do
kind of the same thing over and
over again which is totally
fine it's like what are you expecting
to do write a whole new thing
every time but i feel like if
you watch the the sample and you
feel like you got it yeah that's
it doesn't have your name on it
yeah i don't mean i think once
my special comes out that whole hours
burned you know that's exactly what it
is yeah it's that can be seen
by a stranger might as well have
gone to them i remember
so many comedians in the early days
of twitter was like i'm not gonna
give jokes away for free yeah yeah
yeah you are and you are dan
you're gonna get and you're gonna get
a lot of fights on there i
remember showing one very active twitter comedian
how to sign up for twitter and
they were very much in that thing
of like no i just don't see
how this will work this i mean
i'm
not gonna do these jokes for free
and then i froze ago now can
we talk and i'm scots frozen again
which is going to be just disaster
but it has a look of anguish
on his face which is making it
kind of fun kevin kevin's telling me
to turn off my video so i'm
okay go dark go dark okay zero
dark thirty
a wisconsin hall i want to hear
about your day-to-day and scott can you
hear us yeah i can you okay
great so you're not frozen so this
is going great so paul i wanna
hear about your day because you had
a very exciting takes you met someone
that i idolize yeah you've i you
have a new girlfriend oh lauren idolizes
yes
i met lawrence jeroen she's my new
girlfriend
jenny doesn't hear this um i was
invited to ah mr bob odin kirk's
hollywood walk of fame ceremony where bob
got star of the walk of fame
that's so crazy because i've seen these
know they post these on like people
instagram and like you'll see him
on entertainment tonight like they aren't getting
there started and i always think it's
so cute but i never really thought
about there being an audience that's like
people who were invited as opposed to
i always picture just being whoever is
on the street kind of just gathering
round yeah because it's like the person's
friend you don't know who they are
you know you know their family um
especially if it's like an older person
then it's like oh no your grandkid
shades you fuck yeah fossil yeah um
but bob invited ah it was it
was weirdly like a wedding for one
person in my wedding
it's so nice talking with you being
without being invisible nothing to see you
surprise made it incorrect still sad yeah
exactly
just piping in from dimension huh
so the way it doesn't billy idol
doesn't get a lot of credit for
how he talks about how what a
nice day it is you know and
you know no no billie eilish doesn't
get enough credit just as a person
we need to bow down okay why
don't they collab is billy idol alive
yes if you're lucky
but oh well i paid i paid
in which to put a curse on
him and he's still walking
so bob invited me to this and
it was people from all different parts
of his life you know messiah
got it but it ah um and
so i was there ah david cross
was there the cast of better call
saul they were all there um vince
gilligan he was there ah peter gould
co-creator ah the only other people from
mr show that way
were there were invited apparently were billowed
and kirk who got coven and couldn't
come and john ennis who got covert
and couldn't come huh sad now why
was my hero there well i'll tell
you no one knows are you serious
one of the people at this thing
well
i mean someone knows but we did
not we were not told um one
of the people there was fucking carol
burnett and who is that someone was
fucking her
i didn't want to make the joke
but getting there and i know i
know i feel sad i'm sorry joe
but for for real guy was fucking
her yeah it was weird
ah ah i did not know they
knew each other and then david cross
got there and you know we were
talking for a little bit and he
said did you see carol burnett is
here and i said yeah and he
goes i didn't know they knew each
other and i thought he would surely
know how they knew each other but
yeah not i think they were working
on something together
now yeah as we speak oh they
want raymond during our show they're not
listening i here's what here's my theory
is that they are practicing islands in
the stream together and they're gonna oh
and they're going to do it instagram
i would wear the suit me love
that guy would do i
but to tear to your bob sing
islands in the stream would be wonderful
awesome
this dray what if they're doing a
competing three-time style podcast together with one
other person we like mike urban trout
and we never know when he's gone
because we can't see if you've rose
he literally is like having a ghost
and it's like sometimes what happened yeah
one year though
yes honey go ahead you go um
tell me how the how the deeper
yeah when i heard it for like
two seconds and then it's such a
disaster we have to do it on
zoom everyone because ai just got over
cobb and b i'm shooting something this
week and my my schedule does not
allow for anything else yeah so
so we have to do this at
night and it's just it's just a
little much and i have chronic halitosis
which i will not do anything about
even when we're outside i'm like whoa
buddy oh yeah well i really push
it when we're outside i'm like yeah
hey let's play the three jaw
oh fan that i put right mouth
oh so there's a video of the
of the hollywood walk of fame ceremony
now i wanna know tom tell us
a little about in case we don't
feel like watching that i was younger
i'd never been to one of these
things before and you know i was
ah excited to go and i thought
this is such a weird thing and
because knowing bob um
it's like ah of course he's he
you know deserves this kind of recognition
for his work and the way you
know you you you essentially you submit
to ah the hollywood chamber of commerce
and the you know the city councillor
went right okay because that's how i
was wanting
i know that you have to pay
ten thousand dollars yeah for your star
it's not given to you however it's
a great honor so anyone yeah much
do whatever you're doing and not everybody
you can't just pay ten thousand dollars
you automatically get no no you be
lie get approved and then you yeah
yeah yeah so um you know but
it's not like bob is not the
most hollywood of people
you know what i mean so what
it was like a weird thing and
he recognized that too and so um
so it's all these were all gathered
around on little folding chairs um and
there's ah there's a ah like a
red carpeted davis where ah there's a
podium and mike and um and people
speak firs
people get up from the chamber of
commerce and they say they're whatever and
and by the way were you tested
for covert or was that just a
coincidence oh because it was all outdoors
wow it was all outdoors so they
had to people had covert and they
couldn't come yes but i think they
tested before either that day or sometime
just coincidentally they have found out
yeah maybe felt sick exactly exactly so
um when it starts you know that
the ceremony is about to start because
this music starts playing and it is
the the classical song hooray for hollywood
and it plays for i want to
say nine seconds and then it somewhat
vagrancy a long time that's quite lucky
yes i thought it would place you
there like get your attention and then
would keep playing until everybody really should
it's like let's have a moment let's
yeah let's use the song and have
a good time and it plays up
until the like the initial hooray for
hollywood and then it sort of starts
you know the the chorus starts again
and then they just like faded out
abruptly down so crazy
i want to put it really made
me like this event like oh um
i agreed to have a different computer
yeah i switch computers but this one
i don't know guys you just took
one off the pile yeah have you
been having fun without me well he's
no lanie it has been fun at
all but he's been explaining how the
hollywood star ceremony
oh yeah yeah missed very little you've
got to pay you have to pay
like thirty grand for it right i
thought it was ten thousand oh i
think yes i heard it was five
hundred dollars okay i'm looking i heard
it's ten cameos
it's a fifty five thousand dollars i
was paying ah okay so ah now
that makes more sense to be honest
ten thousand did seem low given how
few areas of the sidewalk are left
that's usually why ah like with in
bob's case i think why it's happening
when better saw call better better so
call comes oh shit that's the episode
title because bob doesn't want to pay
for it himself obviously so but yeah
he uses it as for exact you
know show yes yes yeah hey yeah
yeah yeah like yes again we submit
you for this are you okay with
that oh well i love i love
that yeah but like that's that's why
i think weird al for any didn't
get her
his for a long time because you
know a label isn't gonna pay for
it or anything but like throwing either
bow if your your riches greece's gonna
see that but anymore i mean by
that i or someone has said that
and i don't know what i mean
what he's a greek person or a
god maybe creases and i was very
rich oh
zach galifianakis said it i think in
between two friends i'll agree riches creases
yeah crisis what does that i wrote
it but you don't know it's he's
ah yeah he's a dude i'm looking
at now crisis was the king of
lydia who reigned from five eighty five
until his bc until his defeat by
the persian king cyrus the great in
five forty seven five forty six bc
creasy says we're known for his wealth
will not don't make fun of him
and making fun of how they wrote
this thing in there saying he was
defeated in like five forty seven or
five forty six percent
did you see i don't fucking know
did you see that twitter thread that
the gilbert guide did oh my god
what's his deal guys you know i
i'm sure some department i loved i
loved over deal with dilfer know he's
got a role my job but i
love that comic when i was in
like fifth grade i went what did
you love advice i just thought it
was fan
tastic i don't know what it is
went upside down isn't it doesn't have
to do something to do with like
himba work something that you like didn't
relate to it all the whole thing
i think i don't know why i
just thought he was i thought my
right eye when i was a kid
i loved the lock horns oh ah
oh i just understood that name
right they didn't like each other thanks
um wait oh so gilbert ah said
calling joe said over but they grow
followed and kirk dover got on twitter
pub
he is kind of a zil billboard
gets on stage and he's like there's
a lot of similarities between bob wilber
later like if they did a live
action gilbert bob might get the call
i love that yeah no no you
know who delbert is drew carey it's
like gilbert's design after d-ring carry gotta
be yeah i'm gonna put over gilbert
made this thread where he was
talking about it was just like listing
it was like a list of numbers
of like the number of times i've
done this the number of times ah
these this happened to me the number
of things this blah blah blah and
i was like this weird list out
of nowhere and one of the ones
with
number of times fifty thousand dollars has
been stolen from me five to seven
i'm sorry hose how
what's going on but really what i'm
like one time would be mortified tilburg
get it together five times atrocious but
then i don't lose either it was
either five six or seven i'm not
sure whether fifty thousand dollars stolen from
me yeah gilbert's real idiot someone needs
to handle his finances
hand was the problem gilbert get your
finances handled and buy a cameo from
me that's a good way to invest
actually when you buy a cameo it
appreciates in value so yes you should
buy they're not fungible did i ever
tell you but the cameo i've received
i think gift know it's of matt
roloff from the little people big world
and my friend jimmy fowlie bought it
for me and mike because we love
that show show and um it was
fantastic and matt talks at length and
also to try jimmy jimmy made him
try to convince us to get on
cameo so he spends a lot of
the cameo
talking about why cameos great well that's
nice it's fantastic and how often do
you watch it again never and i
don't know where it is
no way i don't know how to
access it i don't know where it
went i tried to ask jimmy to
send it again i bet it's in
the cloud from some cloud so so
yeah so everybody's gathered around on the
side of this little davis and some
seats are better than others right oh
my can you tell me a little
of the
i'm so glad people that are like
the vps are are directly in front
of the thing but they're still looking
at a profile view of bob because
he is facing this bank of cameras
video cameras still cameras and um you
know kind of giving this his everyone's
talking
ing to them right yeah so racy
horn from better call saul got up
she g did very lovely and heartfelt
um sort of tribute to bob and
working with him and what ah what
a wonderful ah colleague and friend that
he is to her than ah david
cross was introduced he was very funny
of course he
was shitting all over the whole thing
my head but it was but it
was funny like you really made me
laugh um and then ah then there
was like just a ton of pictures
being taken with various combinations of people
you know and the whole time i'm
all i'm thinking about is i want
to get a picture with carol burnett
like this is not a thing that
i ever do with people
and i'm like ah there's like so
few people that i would do this
with and i'm like i gotta do
it but i'm so scared to do
it because it's just like i don't
want to bother her and you know
i i've i've everyone saying everyone that
has met her that's around there's like
no no she's she's totally she's so
nice about it she's great everything i'm
like yea i understand
that intellectually but i can't make myself
understand it emotionally and so um i
wanted to take a picture of the
star by itself but there was like
a little reception afterwards and carol burnett
started to leave and i was like
oh i gotta i'm gonna do it
and i'm like i'm i'm literally like
starting and stopping
myself like walking forward and stopping because
i don't because it's like well now
she's leaving she doesn't want to be
bothered she wants to get the fuck
out here right and so um somebody
somebody asks like do you think she'll
be at the luncheon and they said
oh yeah i'm probably pretty sure that's
where she's headed now so i was
like okay so i have a second
chance i'll come back and take a
picture of the star because you're
ark right near it will walk to
the luncheon and then will come back
so um we walked to the luncheon
ah somehow ah everybody gets there before
us it takes so long to walk
there i've had people have been there
for a while carol burnett is there
i'm like okay i'm not gonna run
right up to her and everything and
it's also it's a very
a heady experience for me because um
there's all these people that i have
been watching admiring on television that are
at this thing and there's hanging out
and i'm like i don't wanna go
near a anybody yeah i don't want
to go i don't want like strike
up a conversation people can not have
been nicer everyone was very friendly and
and you know and so
um so finally ah ah like carroll
is guys again on her way out
and ah it was racy horn who
likes like stuff like stopped because she
met her beforehand dinnerware and everything just
like oh carol i wanna like she
looked like racy and looked over at
me like i hey i'm we're gonna
has to happen yeah that's nice yeah
and so this bother me a little
bit i hand my phone to janie
ah and she's gonna take the picture
i get next to ah carol we're
like ah sitting there then the professional
photographer of the event comes says here
i got you guys
and then it's like move back into
the shade a little bit you know
because it's too bright and all that
so move back and now so janie
has just these pictures of us looking
off in the distance because this guy
stepped in and got us full on
and i'm like i don't know i
guess i'll i'll find the watermark version
on
yeah but i there was then there
was a you measure in lincoln i'd
be on like a breakdown hollywood reporter
like who was an attendance and maybe
yeah but i did but there was
another picture where there were other people
in the photo they were out of
frame justin they were like off to
the side just enough that i was
able to crop them out and post
the picture that i posted on her
back and it was she was so
so nice and ah charming and funny
and you know it was it was
an extremely exciting moment for me yeah
that's okay wow mary did a pilot
with her like probably five years a
man was at the taping of that
which i auditioned for that pilot was
i never wanted anything so bad as
i know it was really fun and
it was she was so
hilarious like when she walked on stage
in the show and choose being so
funny it was like it was like
i got chills like it was just
like i'm so awesome who married so
when married yeah and i was just
so proud of her um no but
when when when carol like she comes
down this this staircase and she's being
funny and it was just like oh
i can't believe i'm in the same
room as this person it's like seattle
like the drapes from gone with the
way she might as well you know
in my memory she does like i
know she didn't but like that's what
it was and it was just great
do you think in better call saul
they'll include the take where bob had
the heart attack and just like you'll
see just for a second like him
clutches heart and that it
like like edits to the next the
next issue i that would be if
if somebody there's this thing on youtube
called star trek intakes where this this
guy takes bloopers from star trek and
he puts them in the scenes that
they were in right so the scene
the scene plays like normal
with one person just doing a crazy
thing and then the scene continues like
normal it's really really funny and if
they did that with
oh or like all of a sudden
jimmy falls on the floor scene just
go
but now this was my second time
seeing carbon and in person the first
time i did not get to speak
to her but it was when she
was a guest on watch what happens
live on the bravo network because i
had a friend who was producer for
that show and you know they have
a secret little ah tiny like ten
person audience at that show
yeah it's off camera i wasn't going
at once just yeah right so you
saw those folks and so i was
i was invited to be in there
because my friend knew how much carbon
meant to me and so i was
there watching the interview do you remember
when andy cohen's dumb fucking dog snapped
at her face yes it was a
big butts yeah
yeah her over nets face yes your
face off dumb ass dog tried to
do since he's oh he has since
re-homed the dog yeah no kidding because
they died a number of things like
that and then he um andy had
a child and that was you know
and he had a jaw
yeah what are you like oh i'll
just have this instead let's get rid
of this dangerous month and his son
likes oh no you can't rehome the
kids if everyone is trying to bite
ah carol burnett's face off yes son
his son did that yeah yeah his
sense it's his son did that is
his done did that send to the
just got the dna results back his
son is one hundred percent that bitch
well that's a really fun day that's
very exciting it was a fun day
it was very strange and surreal and
in a lot of ways and you
know i got to meet john carlos
zito and we talked about ah like
bob
rob prompted him to talk about it
called the best worst thing the documentary
about the sondheim musical merrily we roll
along oh yeah i oh man if
he's worth watching yeah yes him jason
alexander it's like waits for fly or
back back in like nineteen eighty or
whatever yeah before humana oh they were
stars wow
wow about this very ambitious and strange
sondheim musical that was ah it's told
ah backwards everything it's it's like nato
or like betray exactly or betrayed this
bird betrayed with a little momento mixed
in betrayal but yeah and so is
it
oh yeah i'm sure that's greenery made
recently or it's an old document the
documentary is also backwards which is very
hard to learn to turn yeah
it starts with the words the end
it's a pretty recent documentary but there's
a ton of archival footage and photographs
and they interviewed the people and it's
it's really absolutely worth watching because as
i was saying it starts from the
point of view of these characters as
middle-aged people older people looking back at
their lives and so they d age
age throughout the show and and it
ends with them is like bright youths
who have optimism and all this kind
of stuff yeah oh wow it's it's
a great idea but like to have
the same people do it it's it's
kind of i think about this a
lot when i see um actors and
old age makeup like young actors
like jagger hoover yeah exactly but i'm
like this is us oh my god
it's gonna end with them being babies
again i've never seen i don't know
what if it ends with their parents
how i watched every single episode never
say and do cry and cry and
cry you know every once in a
while they'll get a tear out of
mail he'll squeeze a tear out of
that onion of an
eyeball you have yeah and you say
this is a you got me i'm
really looking forward to seeing how they
wrap it up there's only five episodes
left oh my god lorry must be
so excited you know about the merrily
we roll along movie right if they're
making don't know about no tell me
about this well it's it's richard link
later and he's going to film it
over the next twenty years
years with what is them wrong with
this guy
but this is his fucking thing that's
his thing now but but it's with
ah ah what's her name ah god
all i can think of his beanie
beanie siegel who's a rapid nauseam yeah
yeah beanie feldstein and in one other
person and so they're the team steam
they're shooting it backwards um so when
they're young
young they're gonna shoot the end and
then they're yeah going backwards and all
that but it sounds cool it's so
much as somebody that's in their twenties
to put on a bunch of slop
on their face and then act like
oh is this man that's many moore's
job for the last six years and
it is it is fascinating she just
was posting about how to just have
the last day of old age makeup
and she didn't
forty five times this season alone this
amazing oof no no it seems like
a pain in the ass i did
it once on the bang bang tv
show and it was in three and
a half hour process i think and
then an hour to take it off
tv just so i mean yeah i
just can't imagine being like on star
trek and having to do it every
single day yeah man
i don't i that is like when
you you sign up to be a
series regular who's a weird space monster
yeah and you're saying well okay i
will be at work every day at
four am and everyone else will arrive
three hours later if you're lucky get
like a weird nose and that's it
just a weird nose rich absolutely yeah
like what's her name
i'm on deep side ah nana visitor
i loved when um you could tell
that every like fourth episode like voyager
when they're they're just constantly encountering new
aliens and that every fourth episode they're
like this guy's just got a weirdness
we think it's time we can make
a hole
and this guy just has a weird
nose in that but it's always the
nose it's never just like the ears
sometimes it's years well it spock is
just the years now and the eyebrows
yeah just the ears when you're in
bed do you ever say just the
ears yeah
i say cradle the nose work the
ears
i tell you what i tried to
put that into a script that we
hope sylvester stallone was good yes you
did
you did
oh my god do you know that
story about cradle
never mind wait
come on you gotta you gotta tell
it to this little guy god i
don't tell e well it's a famous
like hollywood lore that that some sound
men picked up sylvester stallone's audio during
a break his mike he still had
a hot mic and he was getting
a blow job in his trailer and
it was like cradle the balls
i can't even do it and then
whatever you gonna write go to the
bulls look to chef work the shaft
so so we were we were writing
him this part in shirttail two and
we we we had him as a
fish like going down know a shaft
or something so we were trying to
slow
so you're one of those perverts like
when they make those disney least there's
like a hidden sex in the clouds
and like lad and and stuff you're
like you're basically that you're like here
for sure talmud try keto shaft and
balls referencing here um we we never
think without you it it's more innocent
than what they see people i think
it's sick but i ah
i well you know it's funny because
it's like it's a hilarious quote but
it also i hate reminds me just
of this one sex tip i read
in cosmo when i was the teenager
though i didn't take that bite
i a teenager and it was like
a list of like wages to like
make him hot or whatever the fuck
you wanna ma i don't know but
boy you'll see how i'd settle for
two using their shit you can tell
her fifty because one of them was
literally this cradle his balls like a
baby bird
like a baby bird
i don't even think that would be
i mean realistically i don't even think
here's what i think is like two
hands that's what i think when i
create cradling yeah
like a sick bird that you filed
yeah but toy i never forgot that
feeling when i remembered but yeah i
saw you do it all the time
it's a brandy snifter that's that's the
that's the metaphor i don't think a
lot of teams know about what that
is they should they do know about
baby bird they should
now i don't baby bird how to
types of snifters that they should buy
crazy as balls like a baby bird
yeah it's not sick it's beautiful advice
come did you take a break it
by the way note did you know
yeah i took many breaks because that's
true so your cumulative brace would lead
us to our one br
iq yep alright bye bye bye
oh my god here is i found
it the actual audio i found the
cosmo less oh this will see because
i take ten to see the special
but i'd like either good audio clip
you do okay we're back we're back
this so
thick i found the fucking cosmo article
and sebastian looks i can choose joy
how you relax like that's exactly what
i did me yay read this i
don't know if this came out when
your brain switches to watches
this is sad
anyway number twenty three wait what year
it says twenty times but i twenty
it right hand but that's but this
is when it's online i'm like i
definitely read it in parental i don't
know that i would have been maybe
it would have been around twenty ten
but i don't think so
i mean i read magazine you're so
possible but it wasn't thirty and twenty
ten yeah just like it's supposed to
be slain twenty ten
just like famous people like who kelsey
grammer do you remember that time i
fell off the stage oh my god
we won with a mash up with
bigger thematic
there's this big word falling off a
stage in some sort of performance like
on a children's play or something and
then like they matched up with kelsey
grammars audio of him falling off the
stage and it's so funny what stone
did like ah tumblers run style narration
over it's like can i just read
you this when actually hey
use of this book
oh my god this is so fucking
sick i'm like okay just give us
some tips give us a shout my
brain breakers number twenty three s hold
my balls the way you'd hold a
baby bird a little baby oh wait
so this is men yeah yeah yeah
it's saying here here's how you get
me hot thirty six to ten it's
just one guy
a saying that he likes thirty six
tricks to try this summer make me
miserable your thumb make nookie more exciting
by trying these passion pointers straight from
the men guarantee neither of you would
mind the intense heat from these moves
either of you would mind it when
on the go on my your nipples
treating my balls so delicately it's making
me hot like
the nipples are like nothing blowing boy
there's nothing happened oh my god i
can't read any more of these they're
too hot to handle so you read
one to us and that's hey yeah
that's silly when you can handle hey
how about this grab my button
my with what with god sorry i
can't read it in the in the
first person said oh because it'd be
a drop yeah i'm gonna say grab
his butt with both hands when you're
giving him oral
instead of hands that you know
just i just like you have to
read this and you're using the idea
like just you shouldn't just don't do
it don't do it and try guessing
on the lips
i'm stressed out oh no laundry
just navy of teens so you rent
you read all of them when you
were younger no i know i how
many did you have you like absorbed
through most them all
were you when you're reading it were
you like ooh boy this i was
like haha oh
i have to go to mafs
you've got to break hey you point
you got to break just do make
it to date what's he up to
should we have as a guest mc
hammer yeah ah he appear in some
commercial i think fairly we we can
ah yes where it was like remember
me kind of like we'll go or
get the money you touch that
z bankrupt in binky was bankrupt yes
that was wrong i don't really know
what thing corrupt means like because it
doesn't mean you don't have any money
right i think it means different things
for different people yeah it's basically if
you file for bankruptcy protection that means
that your and i have every day
your your your money is like frozen
and
people can't come get it from you
that they have to work it out
for you like they'll like a creditor
will will work out like ok will
you pay this you know this amount
of cents on the dollar to us
back um but they can't actually like
legally get it from you i see
it's frozen they put a sticker of
elsa on it yeah
so that everyone knows and everybody goes
oh yeah leddy would you like to
buy a snowman i can't i can't
help being corrupt i'm
okay here's the deal if if paige
davis ever guest on the show then
mc hammer can be guessed how about
that i think that's fair i feel
that's fair that's the order goers in
fair the order goes paige davis yeah
mc hammer mary holland knock and you
can't wait on a second
we have sworn that she will never
be a guest on this call what
i'm saying is there's no fucking way
we get mc hammer on this show
if we wait davis will get mc
hammer yeah it's a pacquaio once hammer
years that page did the show yeah
everything will start to come together yeah
that makes sense
that's what you're you're right you're right
it's too risky i can't put me
on the list that's like a real
monkey's paw stuff yeah you're right i
shouldn't put her on i'm taking around
digging around showed as arvo morale i'm
not on the whole mom i'm maria
woo
la la la la lula we really
hit a wall so low
it's tough not seeing la la la
is it isn't helping it isn't helping
because there are a lot of like
facial cues of like okay rapid shot
makes his eyes go real big sometimes
you know like what happened yeah sometimes
he may make a big front face
like scott scott was wrong this is
so vs
this is low will you grab my
balls
show the shaft self knew those moves
zoo zoo instead of demolition man
still the zone you go grab my
cock and balls with both hands and
pull like your life depends on
you want a baby boot meal right
kubu grow my whole my rose like
a little baby bird grab a bottle
bonehead
your love a little bit my ballsy
little paper the cloud of the nest
and then and if you touch me
my mommy won't take me back just
hover your hands right under i'm saying
another common who will just you observe
food spittle baba boy why do my
two of my dick a little baby
balls i tick like a little promote
bowls are currently in a nest what
do you
but like all alone put my balls
in those hammock and let em suing
the food picture for you you will
go to the street you hear the
pepe
you looked out it's boo boo goo
book you said was wrong but boy
could google sli this is just the
intro come sunday but pick up my
posey
cut my balls and hold them up
at a normal height so boom way
above my dick pull them up to
my chest or more wholesome like
good lover who gives you like you're
standing up squeeze the world baboons squeeze
get a little dropper in squeeze of
water of my book bubbles let it
go now like a little like dewdrop
on a flower that a bees about
the suck jesus christ why does the
worst part
that b's about the so sock
my dick like a little big in
a pile and i live a little
flower
oop you joe mclean
oh my
you know if i'll be dead i
yeah i'm i like still hot now
i'm going to go take a dump
let's hey toilet creating my shit like
a little baby hey troy lee
it's like the serie of toilet toilet
toilet toilet receive my shit
my shit toilet flush it away until
my shit got even greater my shit
show deserve it even if that was
a videotape that he put out that
was only five minutes long
the clip itself is what ten seconds
yeah
and then it just yeah intro trump
hook into with two and half minutes
if you if you put that audio
clip over big bird falling off a
stage oh no please don't do this
burn out oh no putting it over
kelsey grammer falling yeah yes greater the
balls guys clean falls down
balls
that
i mean as funny as it is
that must have fucking hurt so worth
it plus you're not expecting to fall
it's like the worst thing i could
see how did it happen it's so
he wrong he basically walked off it
in a weird way like into like
a little pit yeah and he had
a spotlight on him couldn't see shit
so niles wasn't there
to help him there was that dog
and loose eddie eddie played by malin
said winston
so he checked in no no that's
dumb saint dennis dunstan dunstan checked in
but winston similar wishbone a very famous
dog who could travel to dime oh
it was i wish those deal he
was a time traveler yeah he'd be
like here what are we going to
shakespeare's time and now i'm shakespeare and
i'm a dog what way he'd be
yeah
that i you know i don't say
i always flip the channel in wishbone
came on because it was after arthur
and arthur was a little more highbrow
um which bikers to yeah well to
bail you are reading cosmo yeah what
was arthur's whole deal alright there was
a fantastic character he's an aardvark um
actually he recently they recently wrapped up
arthur
and they had them showed all the
characters as twentysomethings wow were they on
the show have a watch because i
heard they're gonna cry right yeah they
were all hot it was i think
there's like eight years old on the
show
were they of legal age to you
know they were like eight years old
they were
i love that show when i was
little yeah so complicated with balls up
but um but i loved arthur and
they also had a segment called a
word from us kids where they would
go to a school and like to
see some kids and they would do
some sort of activity and show you
about it and there was one that's
very memorable which always comes to mind
where these kids were drawing
um different sorts of heroes or something
one person drew paley the soccer player
and then they said pay les paleo
scores great goals
but there's no second part of a
rhyme there was definitely other stuff that
happened but i don't remember anything besides
that and i bet you anyone who
knows i'm talking about only remember that
part hey there was also this one
where they go to a black school
for the blind and these kids show
how they baked cookies and i always
remember that they would tap the they
would hit the um baking sheet with
a spoon to see where there was
a space to put the da so
who's a big issue with his boot
wonder where the chocolate chips like in
braille yeah and then that's not the
recipe the chocolate chips like in braille
yeah scott i've never been more disappointed
in you why i think it would
be a good idea
i've never been disappointed that you haven't
patented something
it would say yeah this is a
chocolate chip cookie
it would say the whole thing
um have either of you guys ever
heard of a show called hodge podge
lodge no no amish i'm curious nor
is it a home makeover show no
it was ostensibly a kid show and
it was this fucking old lady who
lived in the hodgepodge lodge
she was not like a character person
she was just an old lady who
did crafts and she would show you
some crafts and it was so i
know i wish i got to look
forward to youtube because at the time
it enraged me because as a kid
i want to be entertained this was
not entertaining i know it was boring
shit and was that kind of thing
where the
this is supposed to be for me
i think i think this is supposed
yeah aimed at me but i'm not
enjoying it well the worst was when
frugal gourmet would come on
it's like if you're gonna be like
oh boy am i leave it on
if i'm on p b s was
such a minefield because you see something
that was great and then all of
a sudden there's the fucking frugal gourmet
i know can you believe it like
i really got to do whatever the
fuck he wanted well in until he
was caught by the police no one
need to
what did he do yeah i cannot
advise everyone caught by police he sexually
ah he sexually harassed under age ah
ah boys i think it was like
people that worked on the show at
the he was like a predator he
was britain room i o guiding dozen
for thank god thank oh jeff
something right jeff smith ah i bet
his real name is my brother the
first things about him they he settled
oh a sex scandal ruined his career
that's in his obituary six ah six
people oh geez six people alleged oh
my gosh
ha boy you just so we know
what i knew when i got a
bad feeling when i saw him that's
why you would turn it off yeah
it's always always like ooh look at
the heebie jeebies but what about the
cooking cage and justin wilson guarantee from
the big easy oh wait guys and
he also molested a hitchhiker i can't
with this fucking guy
rest in hell hey you know what
you are frugal with your fucking morals
you piece of shit no rest in
piss ride the devil's dick till dawn
the last word and let the devil
shaft work it's way into your throat
anus wherever
okay guys let's take a break
ah
and we're back and i like it
we're gonna attempt to three ch her
here on shitty internet um this one
is called press junket submitted by k
p thomas press junket
i wonder if featherly chicago chicago shit
or not she internet lauren you've cracked
it i wonder if i'm sanctioned a
troll toes k p duties i've got
kitchen patrol his name is k p
duties the person who submitted the campaign
kitchen and k p thomas
k p duty high memcpy duties and
iowa i'm here to introduce sylvester stallone
for good but first a word about
kitchen duty fall in the toilet
hello toilet hey toilet man who got
hit with a brick
um ok so this is ah
wait no no no this isn't what
i wanted to do oh geez huh
p thomas you're out this is anchors
away this this is the first one
when i looked earlier okay this is
okay submitted by sean
one name wow because right areas yeah
how is it spelled s h a
w n okay i that's what i
thought for some reason interest that's what
i pictured in our eugene yeah
okay so feature this is anchors away
this is ah three of us play
two head anchors on a new show
and then the third is on the
scene reporter during the same broadcast the
head anchor or one of the anchors
and the on the scene reporter team
up and are aware of something bad
the key
co-anchor did and they continually hint at
the issue seamlessly while doing the broadcast
the topic is agreed upon we're gonna
text each other before it starts and
the other anchor tries to guess what
the two are hinting at i look
i love every variation of the same
game
and this one is no different i
can't wait to play it so here's
scott
scott where where do you want to
be great great great i'll be whatever
since i don't have a camera what
is what say you should be the
on the scene yeah okay and then
um which one do you want to
be called the co-anchor or the head
anchor you're tricking are being tricked ah
i'll be tricked okay
so i'm the head anchor and scott
and i will work together we'll text
each other what you did and we're
gonna work on getting back to you
asap a safety
oh just hold onto your head and
in other news all of the puppies
are free now so they're running around
the park and they will be available
for adoption if any of them make
it back to the park great stuff
really good to hear that yeah ah
we go now with a story following
up on a story we were talking
about earlier there was a big ff
fire at one of the big buildings
downtown and we have a reporter down
there right now mitch koran corrado mitch
carano down there on the cnn what
can you mention a bitch what's going
on buddy guys
really wish you wouldn't call me that
i've i've asked you several several times
to oh yeah especially especially on air
but i think good fun and i
feel like you're asking us not to
do it also in good fun so
i'm gonna continue to i now have
people on the street coming up to
me calling me bits of the day
they're not even calling me mitch
it's they're just calling me bitch the
mitch that might just be what they're
calling you i don't know but i
think it's from you tell us about
the fire
alright well um the fire ah as
you can see it's still blazing behind
me it's been going on for now
seventy two hours ah only one building
they can't seem to get it out
that they've run out of water and
ah
it is a it's a restaurant um
and of course you know restaurants ah
very well um ah you do we
really do buddy who will you know
well you know cooking
yeah i mean yeah you're familiar with
what happens in them and ah so
let's ambitious this we can't we can't
see who you're looking at it would
help if you use our name talking
about you what are your names again
we've never discussed oh well obviously my
co anchor here is ralph real riff
oh really well for the delf that's
right
i'm a dad you would like to
fuck
according to the poll that we took
over liberty weekend and thank you to
everyone who voted me a dead that
you would like to fuck would you
call me a bitch because of a
poll that people voted on um yeah
sure
and obviously my name is runt runt
ralph and run why have we never
talked about your names i've worked here
for well we're not the news we
report the news and we don't like
any part of this matter but the
who the mouthpieces now can we just
get back to your mouthpiece well if
you love to eat but you don't
love to speak
i love to eat but i don't
love to swim like when it's when
it's benefits you don't yeah you don't
speak yeah exactly you hold your tongue
but then when you when you want
something you lap it up yeah you'd
you certainly do a lot a lot
like some of the bystanders here who
are refusing to talk about who set
the fire
yeah right bitch have the fire department
released the names of any suspects to
any cause of the fire well i
mean i don't know why you would
be so concerned about that ralph um
because aren't you used to just kind
of turning your back to that kind
of thing now bitch when we talk
about that well we mean by that
is that of course i'm just clicking
on the same page as you
that ralph is somebody who doesn't really
stand up for what's right yeah yeah
i beg your pardon what did you
say yeah what do you stand up
for up for what's right and yeah
you know i mean it's not like
you care about people taking personal responsibility
so why do you care if they
found a suspect or not okay well
it is part of the news and
i it sounds like you're acute
oozing me of something and and something
to do with food and restaurants and
eating not speaking not standing up for
someone and i think it's that ah
someone i saw someone be slapped at
a restaurant and i didn't say anything
well i'll tell yourself this one is
that easy this was one of the
few restaurants that catered to a poorer
clientele people who were
we're very concerned with how they spent
their money i'm sure penny pinchers i
don't know of another way to say
this but they were there with their
money they certainly we were thoughtful about
how they spent about how they spent
it yeah and unfortunately this place is
now gone i actually think i think
google was named after this word
i mean it certainly rhymes with it
but
but ah in any case
i mean because google is a free
search engine and and the word that
rhymes is a cheap way to be
yeah that's true but ah and really
you're saying froogle froogle whoa yeah you're
saying is one so you're saying i
believe if i if i'm correct and
we'll get back to the fire just
a minute bitch but what you're saying
is that is that i'm i'm i'm
a cheapskate well you're saying you
you certainly interacted with one quite a
lot when your good friends quite one
very famously frugal and um yeah very
famously frugal and also ah you know
was a restaurant tour of sorts and
a creep ass
ah you might be talking about my
friend ah jeff smith ah if i
if i'm not much mistaken and of
course i have i have a detailed
our relationship and how i didn't know
what he was doing at the time
and that's why i never said anything
yeah it looks like the fire bitch
has gone down completely behind you because
you know
yeah it actually just burnt out just
while we were talking because the hearing
is gone the buildings totally down the
people are gone and everything has gotten
so that was um horrible reporting on
your part bitch and i yeah it
was not paying attention sorry yeah i
do hope that um the firemen weren't
just listening to us and they were
trying to put the fire out but
maybe they were they were pretty distracted
by me because i was waving to
them like hey i knew
need to talk to you during this
whole thing row right right right well
mitch the bitch thank you for that
report ah to shame it wasn't more
informational but ah that is the news
game anyway i am selling copies of
signed um recipe books from just myth
the frugal gourmet um at a discounted
price i was
trying to be clear these are recipe
books is about cookbooks these are just
recipe book the recipe recipes for which
you how to cook anything ah they're
just there actually to be strictly fair
they are ingredient books these are just
lists of the ingredients that are in
certain dishes so it's basically a dictionary
but only the food looks that's exactly
right and there are enough medical order
and
ah there's no um um of amounts
listed no uniform measurement it is strictly
just all the food words generally it's
a logically dick leave strategically politically which
is what i nicknamed jeff smith the
frugal gourmet strictly tickly yeah okay i
knew i knew about it i knew
about all oh we knew it you
you're a bad person this is my
final broadcast and rent i want to
say what a pleasure has been serving
by your side and mitch the bitch
always a pleasure to see you standing
in front of a building that burned
down i love yourself i love you
too i love you both yeah i've
never said if i were i love
you guys too yeah and i've never
said that at all to anyone do
you
i could have your job are you
able to name your successor or because
i'm tired of being out here in
the cold i think because i am
disgraced i don't think they're gonna let
me name my successor yeah being disgraced
is a part of is a problem
for that yeah yeah yeah yeah so
i don't know i might be up
to run here yeah rats do you
i mean do i have a shot
or uh
replacing him yeah yeah yeah i have
a few other people in my mind
are younger you think for mitch the
bitch um there's this cool guy named
sly who has a lot of stuff
i was always super yeah
welcome to the i was in the
next studio over is go weather
he's gotta tell you bill is ramen
yeah right
it's an it goes weather
yeah so him
alright well i'm gonna quit okay well
i'm going to stay because i now
finally gonna break the glass ceiling and
i'm just curious what that feels like
and on behalf of myself runt mitch
the bitch and all of us here
at the www pdx family i really
wish you wouldn't speak for me goodnight
hey
and don't forget to be a tattle
tale
alright funny combine good three ch or
get three cheers thanks varsha that sorry
shaun this thing and it was great
shandy great sorry k p we didn't
get to that always k p sean
was wanting to gun acacia under good
cora lee yeah sorry k p constantly
poorly that's what kpi stands for
wow spelled wrong that's great yeah even
that i know he was poorly don't
love it i love it so much
i love it oh i want to
say limit so much love it so
much due to total total zones or
zonal zonal ballsy magu pelicans ah
alright good dating this is it we
have characterized this way what a wonderful
weird episode we just had it was
really a weird episode and i hope
everyone loved it and i really hope
you all get a cameo from paul
i hope i do too i hope
you do too um listen we're threesome
usa on twitter and instagram we are
three
freedom usa a gmail dot com we
have a phone number don't know what
it is now we i mean we've
refused to look it up maybe somebody
could put it in the chatting i
don't think it exists yet know we
recorded an outgoing message yeah and and
yeah they're slow to know we really
we made that a priority to record
an outgoing message for
i'm still in the works kevin says
still in the works well hey everybody
a i guess you know just keep
an ear out for that ah phone
number
it's still in the war i'm sure
if you follow us i mean you
know how hard it is to get
a phone number have you ever read
hear that one here's why we're it's
taking so long we're paying for new
numbers to be made and yeah because
we hate so you've heard of zero
one two three four five six seven
eight nine we're trying to trying to
get ten and eleven and twelve put
wow yeah see i know we're trying
to get ten eleven and twelve put
onto the phone number allison we're trying
to get fly around and limb yeah
ah do you know how about that
fuckin remember selena barnes and now selena's
dead and now it's just the barnes
firm injury attorneys to avoid eight
eight million wow that's sad i didn't
know that ah florence is gone or
whoever you're talking to more selena selena
cilantro i'm really sorry i was our
cilantro ever got shot in the fucking
head by looking for leo
alright goodbye to long night bye
ugh